Janice is famous for saying I make love  to 10,000 people every night and I go  home alone she was making real music and  she didn't there was nothing else in her  life that was working nothing she's  trying to live it and you can't you  cannot live what you are onstage in the  normal world you've been dancing with  God for two hours and you're feeling  everything and it's all okay and then  you jump on the bus and it's quiet and  there's nobody and they've left a bottle  of wine on the table for you and there's  a candle lit and you're like this and  you've got to calm yourself down and  you've got to get some sleep and you've  got to do it all again tomorrow  you